this is a production of Cornell
University
welcome to this floor cast episode on
understanding compost vermicompost and
teas the purpose of this flora cast is
to introduce the listener to several key
concepts related to using compost
vermicompost teas and extracts as well
as to describe their use in certified
organic production systems in the
greenhouse composts are simply organic
matter that has been subjected to
decomposition in a controlled process
compost can be useful in substrate
production because they can be a source
of microbes for example for suppressing
root borne diseases composts have a high
cation exchange or nutrient holding
capacity and the compost itself can be a
slow-release nutrient source and
container production mature compost
should always be used in mature compost
can be high in ammonia and volatile
organic compounds which can be damaging
to plants in certified organic
greenhouse production composts are
allowed according to National Organic
Program and opie guidelines so long as
the following criteria are met the
compost should use approved feedstocks
which include many plant and animal
materials that are not contaminated with
prohibited substances such as herbicides
minimum temperature requirements must be
met during the composting process one
thing when using compost and container
production are that all composts are not
created equal therefore one cannot
assume that all composts can be used in
container production and it is important
for a grower to test different compost
sources as well as batches to ensure
that the material is suitable I like to
think of compost using the sausage
analogy that is all sausages are not the
same sausages will have different
feedstocks and/or meat products used in
making them as well as different curing
processes and ultimately that's going to
affect whether you have an Oscar Mayer
wiener or a very nice polska kielbasa
there are some steps that you can check
to make sure that your compost is
suitable for container production and I
do recommend that you test each batch
from a supplier
suitability now let's move on to talk
about vermicompost very simply
vermicompost can be thought of as worm
worked waste worms will digest and
fragment the feed stock into finely
divided materials vermicompost is not
just the poop or the castings from worms
but also the other organic matter that
the worms have divided up the
vermicompost can be a useful material
because it is because it is finely
divided it is enriched in nutrients it
contains more soluble nitrogen
phosphorus and potassium than a standard
compost an example of vermicompost een
that's done on an industrial scale is
available at worm power LLC in the
process the manure solids from a dairy
operation are collected these solids are
then brought into a warehouse where they
are thermophilic li composted in static
piles this then serves as the feedstock
for the final step which is feeding this
material to millions of red wiggler
earthworms according to the National
Organic Program guidelines vermicompost
is allowed in certified organic
production so long as the following
guidelines are met the vermicompost
material should again be made from
allowed feedstock materials and the
duration of the vermicompost in process
should be six to twelve months for
outdoor wind rows two to four months for
indoor container systems two to four
months for angled wedge systems and 30
to 60 days for continuous flow reactors
now let's move on to talk about compost
teas compost teas are liquids that are
made by brewing are steeping compost in
water this process serves to transfer
microbes fine particulate organic matter
and soluble chemical components such as
plant available nutrients from the
compost to the liquid the benefits of
compost tea are that it contains some
nutrients as well compost teas can
contain a beneficial microbial community
which might be used for the control of
full urine root diseases these microbes
might also be involved in enhancing
nutrient cycling growers may question
whether or not compost teas work
and the answer again is it all depends
returning to the sausage analogy compost
teas can be prepared in many different
ways and they can also have many
different feedstocks and additives that
are used whether or not you get a
beneficial microbial community as an end
result will depend on all of the
processes that take place up to that
point one of the things to decide when
preparing compost teas is whether or not
to actively aerate it a tea is what we
call the material when we do use this
active process to add air or oxygen
during brewing this is done to promote
the population of aerobic microbes we
refer to the material as an extract when
a passive process is followed that is
oxygen is not introduced during the
steeping process this might be referred
to as a non aerated or passively aerated
extract with extracts there is no need
for specialized equipment and one
advantage of an extract is that it has a
much longer shelf life than a compost
tea in certified organic production teas
and extracts can be used if certain
criteria are met if the material is
prepared without compost additives it
can be used on edible crops without
restriction if the material is prepared
with additives then it can be applied
without restriction if the compost tea
production system and materials have
been pre-tested to meet EPA guidelines
for a bacterial indicator of fecal
contamination if the above criteria are
not met then the particular tier extract
must be applied 90 or 120 days prior to
harvesting and edible crop ninety days
in the case that the tea or extract
material does not come into direct
contact with the produce and a hundred
and twenty days prior if the material
doesn't come in contact with the
particular produce a reminder that
organic producers should always consult
their certification agents before
purchasing or using products as well I
was conduct your own in-house trials
with new materials
until next time
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu